pull up this tweet from Andy no we have
this this is shocking a shocking
Revelation Andy no initially reported
this morning before we got new
information at least 23 stop cop City
suspects were arrested in Atlanta on
suspicion of domestic Terror over the
violent Ambush on police almost all are
from out of state one of the terror
suspects is a Southern Poverty Law
Center staff attorney
and another is a Canadian academic story
to come this is crazy the splc has
responded by admitting that their guy
was there this is shocking you'd think
they want to deny and be like nope nope
no oh no they outright said it law
enforcement detained at least 35
demonstrators in Atlanta including an
splc employee who was arrested while
acting and identifying as a legal
Observer on behalf of nlg news I would
just like to point something out
if uh you're a lawyer and uh you're with
a bunch of people who just who have said
to rob a bank and you go into the bank
with them and you're dressed like them
I'm sorry you're an accomplice this is
not a protest the the legal observers
typically go to demonstrations or people
are marching down the street and they
watch and then when the cops Act a Fool
they say we saw that
this was a group of terrorists
ransacking breaking onto private onto
Government property and burning to the
ground and then what an splc employee
decided to join them just to watch yeah
you're not exempt from breaking into a
government facility because you're an
attorney for a non-profit so all they've
done thus far is admit he was actually
there they say it's part of a month-long
escalation of police tactics blah blah
blah blah but the fact that a terror a
terrorist cell and a national chapter
anti-fundance International Associates
have support from the national lawyers
Guild in the Southern Poverty Law Center
shows you just how far gone we are and
how close we are to a legitimate culture
Revolution and I'm sure the left is very
excited about it of course they are I
mean they've been it's something that
has been in the works for a lot of years
this is not new this started I I would
say that the foundation was laid in the
80s with Paolo Ferrari's influence in
schools and then with the influence of
Powell ferry in the schools of Education
in the 90s start pumping out these kids
from the humanities departments that all
believe that essentially socialism is
the way I think it goes even farther
than that what was the Long March since
in the institutions yeah the 60s that
was we started a creep vent right was it
the the term was coined by uh Antonio
gramsci who was a uh like McCarthyism
and all he wrote it in the 20s wow
really yeah Antonio Graham she wrote
from an Italian prison in the 20s and
he's the one that's came up with the
idea that you had to go through the
institutions and change the culture and
they did and that's exactly what they
did well Mao did it and he proved that
it works and now it's being done here
there's a couple ideas pertaining to the
Long March to through the institutions
and uh Yuri besmanov of course most
people who watch the show are familiar
with talk about the demoralization and
the subversion of the United States this
was of course during the Cold War and so
one of the scariest theories is the
Soviet zombie takedown of the United
States and that idea is the Soviets
implanted these ideas into the United
States to basically plant seeds that
would eventually destroy and uproot this
country we may be experiencing that but
the Soviet Union no longer exists so
this is like it's it's it's kind of
creepy it's like almost perfect for a
movie where like a spaceship crew comes
across it'll actually there's like a
Star Trek episode about this they come
to a planet and there's a doomsday
weapon armed ready to go because of a
war that was going on the Soviet Union
like the ghost of the Soviet Union is in
America now that's right yeah it's
correct the Soviet the Soviet exists
it's just not unified as as they were we
were at War they implanted a poison in
the U.S were destroyed themselves but
that poison remained and the attack was
terminal this is a double knockout and I
mean another thing about the
institutions and the universities in
particular was the um critical race
Theory which you know we know about that
now it's actually kind of crazy because
I remember looking this up back in 2016
and it was all this information about
how it got its roots also with the
Soviet stuff because they were wanted to
have a way of like breaking down what
the family unit and and all those things
so that they can be dependent on the
state and what have you but they got its
way into Columbia University with the
Frankfurt School or whatever I found all
this information about it and I was like
researching it if you look that up now
today it says right-wing conspiracy
theory yep like there's no actual
information documents documents about it
and I'm like where did it go it used to
be on the wild wild west of the internet
I found it all the documents there was
like a big moment when Wikipedia I think
they went in and started changing all
the information on the Frankfurt School
calling it a conspiracy theory but it
existed no and that's the academic name
yeah yeah came from Columbia University
Herbert Marcus and and and the scholars
that were that were involved in there
and I mean right now we live in the
logic of Herbert Marquees that's why we
don't have uh the the federal government
going after the left the way they go
after the right the left is apologized
for is made excuses for is allowed to
behave in in violent ways in ways that
are completely unacceptable for people
on the right and according to Mark
Hughes he believes that even the ideas
that would come from the right must be
suppressed let me let me blow your mind
everybody who's listening I have this
article from Fox 5 Atlanta Georgia
Trooper stable after being shot
protester killed near controversial cop
City police facility site it's from
January 18 2023 a police officer gets
shot
they then opened fire on the assailants
killing one of the terrorists how do you
think the guardian wrote about it here
we go the victim assassinated in Cold
Blood activist killed protesting
Georgia's cop City killing of Manuel
Esteban Perez Tehran who opposed
training facilities unprecedented in
history of environmental activism I'd
say you want to know what else is
unprecedented is probably this passage
in their own story officials say Manuel
shot first at a State Trooper without
quote without warning and an officer or
officers returned fire but they have
produced no evidence for the claim
the trooper was described as stable and
in the hospital Thursday there's no
evidence except for the cop in the
hospital
so uh what and that where's their foot
in a level three the footnote was added
on 24 between the final editing and
publication the gbi released information
including a photograph of a handgun and
the agency said was in Manuel Tran's
position the gbil said forensic analysis
confirmed the projectile recover from
the trooper's wound matched this handgun
but there's no evidence see footnote not
only did they have evidence a cop was in
the hospital and they still wrote what
they have produced no evidence for the
claim the trooper was described as
stable in the hospital
so did the bullet fall from the sky what
did did someone in a plane Drop just the
bullet with you know just and it landed
on the cop and he went oh how did that
happen I don't even think a bullet
falling at terminal velocity would be
able to penetrate a human body
it's gross I'm impressed with the with
the media so this is the point when our
institutions are actively defending
terrorism and the subversion of this
country kind of feels like you already
lost but I know I'll tell you the cops
man they played it right this time they
they killed no one they arrested
Thursday they killed the guy oh right
this last time they were able to because
it would have been like three dead in
clash with police or three dead
protesters innocent protesters killed
some you know really manipulative story
they didn't kill anybody they arrested
35 people they charged 23 so far I think
they're doing it right what do you guys
think is worse is it worse if the police
do their job and a protester dies when
the police are trying to you know stop
the violence or trying to detain people
or whatever or is it better for some
people in like like proud boys or
whatever to get fed up and decide
they're going to go encounter protest
and actually get into a fight with him
and and have someone die in that
situation obviously neither are good but
which one's going to have the worst
repercussions on the for society I think
if a group going and fighting with the
cops and getting a kill is worse for
society because it's going to provoke
more there's there's no there's the I
guess you can look at this way my view
is if there is no opposing faction then
you get a Communist Revolution and we
know where that goes if there's an
opposing faction you get a Civil War and
we know where that goes and neither of
which is good not neither is better than
the other I suppose you could argue that
following a civil war if the right
faction wins but basically every single
time we we see a civil war resolve
there's some nightmarish thing that
occurs afterwards for decades I'm still
of the opinion that if we do have a
civil war that that it's going to have
reverberations around the world I don't
know what would happen but there it's
not like we don't get to have a United
States does not have a civil war and
then the rest of the world doesn't react
that's true I want to pull up this image
real quick just so I can people can get
I'll get you get you educated a little
bit I'm not going to pretend to be a
scholar on the Spanish Civil War I just
want to use this map to point out right
now there's a lot of people talking
about National divorce and Civil War and
they're very skeptical they're saying
things like we can't have it we
shouldn't have it well I'm not here to
say we should or showed or anything like
well actually we shouldn't for sure but
they show this map of the U.S and they
show cities and it's the Democrat versus
Republican voting base and they're like
oh yeah like we could have a civil war
now and they show a map of the U.S and
it's like these people don't realize
that even back in the day there was an
urban versus rural divide and they
seemed to think today that there can't
be a civil war because while California
is blue but you know the other states in
the in the Midwest and south are red and
that separates it blah blah blah this is
a map of the Spanish Civil War
territories from 1936 to 1939 as that
and at and as you can see it doesn't
necessarily make a whole lot of sense
logistically it's not like half the
Country Split there's some in 1938 you
had the Republican control in two
different bifurcated areas
in this 1936 they controlled the north
but not just directly below them to
Madrid it didn't quite make sense the
territories that were controlled if
there was a real Civil War in this
country it would not be State against
State it's going to be like every other
civil war throughout history where
extremist factions seized control of
certain areas that's it I think looking
at this map of Spain that there's a
mountain range they're north of like in
the Northeast that may be a divider and
the reason why it's split I don't really
know the history of the Spanish Civil
War to be honest um there are Geographic
you know things that'll be like you know
we'll have a divisions
and you can look at Syria as well and in
real Civil Wars basically what happens
is in an area with a high density of one
political faction they seize control but
that might mean they only control a city
and they don't control the surrounding
areas and they might not have any
control within 100 miles outside the
city at all
I think people don't really they're
underestimating uh the states the blue
States because I'm from New York and
just like you were saying California
there's like more rural areas of
California and New York that people
don't realize they're they're pretty red
if you look at the map also the voting
map of it it's pretty red it's just New
York City Buffalo and that's why they're
all cities and that's why what would
likely happen in a real Civil War is
that the New York Metro would be
controlled by one faction and the rural
areas by others the and then we have
guns too well the problem for a play the
problem for these cities is that they
they need to get resources somehow and
so what would likely happen in my
opinion is that New York with its some
30 000 or so police officers the New
York Metro probably has substantially
more than that and they would easily
recruit surrounding suburbs and and
extended beyond the metro into places
like Connecticut which is only a couple
hours drive they would come to Upstate
New York where it's a debt it's sparsely
populated and just take what they want
it's the end of story so well they don't
have the guns in the city but the
upstaters have the guns except the New
York City Police Department has better
guns substantially better guns and a lot
of them and then you've also got do you
think that they're working for someone
or are they going on behalf of
themselves
they will work for the state because the
state's home absolutely they're gonna
say you want food and they're gonna say
yes I do they say okay they'll fight for
their Community probably a lot of times
they have to bring in federal troops to
fight the locals because right the
problem is these cops aren't from there
the cops don't live around there they
may be in the extended area but
typically what happens is the military
comes to you or the government and they
say we're going to make sure you have
food right now it's really uncertain I
know nobody wants to cut no nobody wants
conflict nobody wants to fight but trust
us we're here to help everybody and stop
the crazy people and we're going to make
sure your family has food I tell you
this these guys like in every country
we've ever seen with conflict they will
I'll keep it family friendly they will
hug the government officers offering
them food if it meant they have some we
see this everywhere you look at
Venezuela the Venezuelan National Guard
are willing to shoot college students
because they're guaranteed food at a
time of Crisis and starvation dude if
there was real chaos people would do
pretty much anything to survive yeah
anything
and they're going to come to you and say
we will destroy you first the first
thing will say look if you're if you're
in these areas you most likely agree
already they don't need to convince you
to anything they're going to be like the
crazy Trump conspiracy theorists who
think lizard people control the world
are coming we need you to stop them and
the people are going to believe it
they're going to turn on CNN and CNN's
going to tell them what to do and
they're gonna say okay look if you you
tell me you don't believe me
take a look at Texas where you've got
adult entertainers dancing for babies
and children with a big neon sign saying
it's not going to lick itself and the
cops going uh listen I can't get
involved here
they're not they're not going to defy
these factions even if the law is on
their side they will not do it they will
do what they're told as per the cult and
New York cops will definitely do it
that's why we have an armed populace but
that means you will get a divide between
urban and rural so the question is just
because the people outside the cities
are armed doesn't mean they're organized
in which case you get a culture
Revolution the government gets taken
over by one faction and immediately
issues sweeping reforms and starts let's
just say removing those dissidents yeah
that's what's happened every time in
history throughout eons of of what we
know of revolution is that swiftly the
government solidifies power and then
takes control of the Crackdown but we're
in a new time with massive amounts of
decentralized information transfer we
can use shortwave radio people are armed
to the teeth at an individual level
house by house it's not it's a very
different experiment the United States
local governments is the is the is like
the central core of the of the country
so like it would be tough to strip the
the key would be to control the airwaves
and manipulate information I think if
you could do that you could get people
force people to keep using your your
money then you will control the the
counter I think I think the issue is
that's what they've been trying to do
clearly
and it's not working because you can't
there's a crypto you just can't it's
like a difference the The Establishment
has has lost control of the narrative
machine but it doesn't mean that some
horrible thing can't emerge it's just
maybe it wouldn't be the establishment
it maybe it'd be some crazy cult or some
some NFL sports team we have a crazy
cult in charge look what they're trying
to do with disinformation they're trying
to suspend censor they're trying to get
laws passed so they can control the flow
of information to control your mind and
they are struggling with it
and as much as I would say
you know the far left extremism is being
placated or accepted the information War
rages on with shows like this the back
in the 70s when Nixon went to China the
general idea was if we expose China to
markets and to uh we welcomed them into
the the global community and we expose
them to markets they will become more
like us and the opposite has happened
the United States because of the the
control that China has over their
population that was an attractive
situation to politicians and people that
you know us that would would look for
power and so what happened was they saw
the situation in China and they've
they've decided that they want that type
of control for the United States and
honestly for the rest of the world when
you start talking about wef and and
things like that if you look at the WD
Wes
website there's all kinds of references
to Global governance Global governance
if they weren't looking to have a
globalized government they wouldn't be
talking about global governance and they
wouldn't be having these these meetings
at Davos with the U.S all the movers and
shakers from the U.N this is a move to
actually make a global communist state
essentially why do you think that anyone
in the United States would want that for
the United States I don't think that
there are very many people that want it
there is an extremist group an extremist
Fringe of the left that do believe that
Global communism is the future and
that's the way forward uh the
dissolution of Nations totally this is
global communism no that's the only way
that it's true government true communism
sorry why the Viet Cong why the North
Koreans why that the Chinese why the why
in Russia is why central planning at all
why why did it happen any point in any
of these countries did this emerge it
seems like it always starts off with
someone that thinks it would be better
if we all work together so we're gonna
make a small Council make sure that we
all work together and then the council
gets power and they're like there's no
way we can make that work let's just
take what we got EU I think it's more so
what you're seeing is like
mold or cancer
these people these far left extremists
who are firebombing this this facility
they have no solutions to anything they
are proposing literally nothing when
Greta tunberg was asked what do you
propose we do said it's not my job to
give you answers well then what are you
doing
you all you're doing is burning things
down not building anything that's
exactly right the whole project of the
left is they believe that the perfected
Society is exists and the way to find it
is to pull apart Society you tear things
down and the more you pull away the more
it exposes the existing perfected
Society that's these that's the attempt
that's where critical theory comes into
play is the whole concept and universe
these universities was how do we
criticize each aspect of society and
culture and that's the whole game and
that's what you notice that left does
everything is a critique everything's a
critique and to break it down what I
find though is that in this Society the
only reason we're able to critique it
with such accuracy is because it's a
free society and if we start clamping
down we'll no longer be able to critique
the problem
and so the critique itself we we must
leave open yeah Society for critique at
all times the reason that Chernobyl
melted down is because people were
afraid to say hey this is bad and this
is this is going on there's mistakes
it's because people were afraid to speak
honestly and openly so you're 100 right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time